[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
or we talk about whatever we want today
we got Slurpee because bar got me a
Slurpee are you sponsored right slip I
actually got a post made it which we'll
talk about later oh now they're all
gonna be one more Bart so good at it
what flavors did you get just coke I
like battle you got coke - yeah like
you're a phony yeah you look like the
ACE not [ __ ] who's the Ace Ventura
Jim Carrey's character when he used to
look like a woman with a little oh come
on Living Colour
yeah yeah Joe calls these handlebars
okay she didn't see the picture I
believe it Joe okay remember I told you
guys after those was a porno where a guy
was sucking his own dick and then the
girls came up and helped him with it I
ran into the same one again
did you what does that mean and you and
you can you kept watching it I forgot it
was that what you don't recognize the
same thing man title no dude okay so all
of you avid porno watchers you know what
the [ __ ] I'm talkin about cuz it create
it's one of those things where you don't
even know and he's doing it you're like
what the [ __ ] bro wait so okay start
close up and you're like how yes and it
pulls out and it's just like I know it's
like it's like a threesome and it's like
it's all glammed outlets like it's
really all just one guy I'm familiar
with the thumb woman no I forgot I'm
just saying that the thumb goes it's a
threesome right and it's like it's like
it's all like well shot and [ __ ] and
then I'm like oh cool like I'm down with
this like highly high production yeah
and so I and so this is what they do on
these streaming sites right they don't
upload the whole thing to upload like
maybe a part of it or our trailer of it
right so that I guess I clicked the
trailer version not the full version
select same thing happens again the guys
laying down in these licks his own dick
like this right
at that point I'm out are you sure he's
a cop wait at that point are you like is
it a guy does he ever oh he is a very
short haircut no no there's two girls at
the end there's two girls at the end of
the edge of the bed that catches him so
he's beating off and he licks it and
then basic basically they help him with
the rest but it's so fast
it's so it happened so fast does he have
a really really really big dick where
it's like he doesn't have to bend over
that much well you said it was pretty
big it was like big enough to where all
he had to do with this and he could lick
it yeah I was like a Hot Dog on a Stick
soon as I see a dude mouth on a dick I'm
out yeah same I would be no but as soon
as that happened before I could even it
was so fast before I could even clip you
busted fast forward the girls come in
and then it's not gay anymore but it
couldn't get gay again understand your
thought process when that is gay where
he can lick his own dick but you guys
touch your own bit with your head we had
this debate yeah that's good we had this
debate okay I lick my hand then touch my
dick and I'm like my hand again but
having a dick in your mouth is kind of
gay okay when this stranger did hand is
kind of gay then it's not big I'm
straight but the dick in my mouth is gay
oh and you're straight yeah I think that
I would it would probably feel good but
I'd be distracted by the fact that
there's a dick in my mouth look the fact
is no you everybody that's flexible
enough will try going down on themselves
at one point in their life I feel it's
like that show we did the Cirque de
Soleil show and and this cat was so
bendable we were like whoa what the [ __ ]
and then the the lady came out and she's
like it remember this [ __ ] you guys were
all there she's like I know what you're
all thinking yes he can yeah
oh and then people were thinking he
could suck his own dick yeah we were all
thinking it and that's why we all
laughed we're like I wonder if he gets
up his own dick like I think I would I
would if I was flexible enough I would
maybe do like a oh oh maybe let me see
if I can do it you would for sure be so
what is it called a no no I don't think
I would feel comfortable with with a
dick in my mouth I dunno I think you're
such a [ __ ] sex lover there's like
you're talking about like you jack off
with two heads
I'm sure if your mouth was like another
component that was off-camera but we
didn't say it on camera private piece of
information no I'm just saying cuz they
hadn't heard the information this is off
camera but I told I told everyone in
confidence exclusive that I I sometimes
I jack off with both hands because like
I'll set the laptop off I'll stroke with
one hand and then i caress my balls like
that makes sense but I asked them how do
you scroll yeah so then I'll so I'm like
this right here's the laptop and then
I'm here first I'll find like three to
six different videos I'm letting load a
home you have a playlist
no not even playlist I'd like to you
know find some good [ __ ] you can prep
your jackoff playlist what we have
multiple tabs I mean no one ever told me
that yeah he likes to let him load up
yeah because he's bad internet okay so
the psychology behind is because your
brain is so desensitized and like you
you need to feed it more to fill up that
level that you're gonna have to have a
lot of tabs open nothing fill it
fulfills it because you consume too much
what does this try to have orgy yeah
right you want the [ __ ] like six people
I just have a complex palate I don't
think you're the only one oh this is I
think this is the normal cross I
wouldn't call it all problem
you more the tiger king of porn exactly
you wouldn't well okay technically what
is the right way to consume the
entertainment because one time at a time
once habit a time yeah but who made that
rule up because these I would say that
most porn eighty percent sucks cuz it's
80 percent of nonsense then why do you
have to go 50 percent until they have to
get some dick sucking in and it's like
they suck at acting they're not turning
me on y'all skip to the same parts
anyways right it's like that's for to
the [ __ ] yes get about 30 seconds of
that you kind of know their style and
you're like why do I have to sit through
a bad [ __ ]
close the tab why are they all open no
because what if she has a dull body and
you want to see like her don't you like
click between tabs as your stroke like
yes yes it's all be here okay so I'm
here and then I'll she's woman
explaining the jackoff exterior
[Applause]
let me do what I want to my be my bottom
line I'm just telling you this this is a
real thing so I'm clicking back into it
and though it's all have the hair and
I'm and then I'm click I'm like okay
okay this is a good feels like a good
moment and then I continuously this is
like going to the buffet and you're
getting like I'm gonna get some tongue
to taste it out yeah I'm gonna get a
crab leg you know then you go oh this
one looks good for that piece and I'm a
skip over here that's why I like
compilations because some people are
like to me they're like DJs and people
who can create a good porn compilation
to me howdy sake school they should call
them the BJ Oh BJ DJ yeah the PJ the
porn J Maxim hey Timmy talks actually
that's just me doing it to me
I don't like compilations too much
though cuz that does the tab work for me
so when I do when I do compilations then
in in in tips description I am a healthy
porn consumer I'll go straight to the
compilation and I don't have tabs I
don't like a compilation if it's it to
like a Lincoln Park song why do they do
the music is the words
only if I can't hear the chick mony oh
yeah why do they always have that Linkin
Park song I prefer when I can't hear the
chicken or the guy I just hear think
important it's really loud it's really
really that's what the guys like yeah
man this way sick they even mute the
[ __ ] moaning what it's just it's a
montage it's a montage I click out
immediately when it's me too I just
don't like music
well you click out of do closes I click
out well no I keep the tab open you tip
what the tabs exist for I got a question
for you if you're supposed to only keep
it to one single page I'm not an expert
in this [ __ ] I don't [ __ ] know for a
fact that that means that I've said it
as a joke I have a problem yes you're
right I'm sorry
no no it's not who knows maybe [ __ ] I'm
trying to reach out we all made fun of
them damn it I actually damn Tim we
could jack off together and I'll see if
you have a problem oh yeah oh okay come
over sure I don't know what is the
standard right way of jacking off
yeah it's burnt pull out one video you
jack off to it
Ouisa [ __ ] well here here do it on this
water bottle here is how to do it
she could do it you could do it you'll
do it right yeah I need to learn from
her probably so wagging it yeah you
probably know let me tell you something
so nowadays they would call that negging
right what's maybe what's making [ __ ]
what are you doing No so when you when
you put someone down oh yeah it's a
stupid like pickup it's a pickup artist
there's a turn like yeah okay so but
like but I feel like stupid went and
they said this on a episode of Riggin
morning - he was like before it's gone
negging we called it just reverse
psychology I didn't even know that I had
done this before
Oh what not accidentally on purpose I
didn't know it's [ __ ] like
manipulating this person right negative
[ __ ] to it it's manipulate like yeah
yeah cuz it's just kind of like you know
it's feel like it you play a little game
yeah because I remember some teasing and
flirting is different from negging I
think negging is just like putting them
down so danger do it right like they
have low so and then you can get them
because you're selfish oh yeah yeah the
intense is strategy that's where as
you're just [ __ ] around with well
because okay so someone wants how I'm
treated they're like oh yeah I don't see
how that would ever work like making
somebody feel like they have to prove
themselves to you and I was like
actually one time I remember back in the
day I had like met this girl who I was
like oh she's attractive I feel this
flirty energy here and we're all like
eating together and I was like yeah so
the subject of fellatio came a [ __ ]
[ __ ] sucking dicks and I was like and I
was like oh you probably got black head
bro head game probably and we're just
making jokes yeah
eventually when when she did dome me up
me it means give head to okay
afterwards you at least see a fallacious
relation an activation afterwards she
was like hmm game whack huh and I was
like oh [ __ ] I mind I did I mind fit
yeah you never said yes it was yeah can
you do it one more time was a pain
attention this you're honest reviewing
opinion was it oh no was good this
really was a great yelp review yeah what
she liked hey hey game still whack but
was it as good as getting Slurpee for
postmates was it I don't know
cuz sometimes when you really want
something and in these times you want to
go outside of your house to go get it
it's really safe to get post mix and
that's how we got these studies dude
sometimes I order lunch I'll be thinking
about what about to have for dinner
doesn't have a breath yeah Wow but they
could deliver food from every restaurant
you can think of right to your door and
what's cool about most means is not only
is it food you can literally get
anything you want like a t-shirt being
in stores you get from you get buy a
laptop yep
you get clothing stars batteries I've
actually used it for battery so no more
trips to the stores because like there's
no more late-night food runs you don't
have to worry about where to grab lunch
anymore did you know that yep just
download post mates on iOS or Android
find your favorites and get anything you
want delivered within one hour
yeah for a limited time postmates just
giving our listeners $100 a free
delivery credit for your first 7 days to
start your free deliveries download the
app and use code after record that's the
code after break down $100 of free
delivery credit with no minimum purchase
for your first 7 days bit when you
download the postmates app anything you
need anytime you need it pops my name I
post made floss before we're just a
single just one strand of flawed you rig
I was I was in house in New York I'd
already showered and got into my PJs
else [ __ ] why just go to sleep
oh you know because I really I I need to
floss yeah long hair
no it's not the same and so I was like I
need the [ __ ] floss and I didn't feel
like you know getting dressed again so I
post mated like a 7-eleven but nah
there's no [ __ ] they have toothbrushes
no floss though did they come all the
way up to your door yet to meet him at
that ma'am the lobby I bet if this was
the ritz-carlton they would have had it
probably have everything they do
I heard they they're really good but I
didn't test their customer service
you've been in one mm-hmm that's it you
set foot and they kicked him up looking
like that
I stayed there as one of the patrons
Danny Bolen yes sir
that's where sir is that before after jk
jk made me rich so relatable very very
um why do you have to Foss I kind of got
used to it because so I never flossing
so I had braces hmm the lady might what
the dantos was like if you want your
your teeth to move faster you gotta
floss man she's like that yeah the
build-up so like the fast the more I get
rid of the floss the easier no so she's
like if you want you braces off quicker
you better floss so I don't really give
you a white stains if you don't floss
thank you all mmm
so you feel really nasty with your
braces yeah gross so I got into the
habit of flossing and then and then
after I got the braces off I still like
I was like I need to floss or wait so
would you use that special floss I have
a hard tip and they have like it's like
you have a little bit of the thing and
then you put it through the thing and
then you yeah is it the same as you know
there's that plastic thing that's like
this with the string in the middle does
that work just as good I love that thing
with braces no no not do something right
now oh yeah that's the only way I love
that [ __ ] breaks what are you should
tell him how you fuss I usually use
either the most professional kind of
this thing or the most personal kind of
oh he just doesn't do it ever once a
month she was waiting for that the whole
time well I mean at least you do it my
friends my friend's girlfriend is a
hygienist and we're eating and she looks
at me and she goes
when's the last time you got your teeth
clean wow she's seven years
she's like my niece it's [ __ ]
hilarious so she'll be like I think you
need to get it clean you could come to
my place we'll hook you up for free and
I'm like okay she goes and you look
pretty dirty so you should probably
shave and I'm like okay thanks this and
this was in a group of people no it's
just Duran under we're having dinner at
my house now we're just eating okay
she's so [ __ ] straight up like this
she's staring at you and Google agency
I've been watching you on your lives and
she's like teeth are [ __ ] all your
wardrobe needs to go
no she's literally like that that girl
that was like my daddy gotta go tooth be
teased like that she straight up she
look at you she goes you've been looking
kind of dirty in your live streams it's
probably the hair here wow that's funny
so sweet we all need people like that
sometimes yeah but she does it in like a
cute little sister way so I'm like okay
thanks hey did I just go to [ __ ]
shave it off you know yeah can you put
your pigtails in I like this style I
also have like I like a little I could
be in between the STT I get pretty hefty
chunks of food in there dude I have one
back here cuz I got my teeth filled in
and then let a little piece like fell
out during the whole quarantine stuff no
and then now I got a [ __ ] ton of stuff
in there oh you should go to the dentist
when it's available cuz it's available
now yeah you could go you could go to my
friends go he says she's like so it's
out in the valley so she's like there's
mad influencers that come every single
time they try to get a like sponsorship
or brand deals and she says it's so
funny cuz every single time she acts
like she doesn't even know what that is
no no Matt you're running a medical
practice and people coming in with like
your Instagram hold up you see this if
they might be for free and cuz in
occupation sometimes when they're
creating they're filed they followers
and she goes oh what's that
and she goes yeah I'm coming like I you
know I have an Instagram page or
whatever and she makes every single time
she loves hearing what they expect yeah
and she pretends every single time like
oh so you get followers on Instagram
that's cool I didn't know that
larry's business and I haven't been
influenced by you she's just a troll man
yeah but yeah they're open dude isn't
that crazy I didn't know that dentists
were essentials I know I just got a text
from my orthodontist you know we did a
FaceTime consult like not consultation
but like a appointment thingy just take
a phone in her mouth she's like you take
the filter off wait I have a puppy years
why did your tooth have a puppy err but
yet I thought that was so strange where
I'm like what was the sign of the times
man I'm facetiming my orthodontist right
now cuz it me and Isaac had the same
orthodontist so she was like looking at
his his like movement and stuff and I'm
like this is and they even get an
accurate reading from like face I mean
well I mean for for that like obviously
you can't do anything so it's more like
has anything poking you like are you
good like oh whatever cuz he actually
like he only has the top braces still
cuz there are two teeth that need to
grow in and before they do everything
but you still wear your retainers I wear
Invisalign mm-hmm but not when I'm
filming because I have a list is anybody
else worried about how we haven't been
working on our immune systems at all B
oh yeah away so it's a proper wet foot
no go ahead you're very Saints those are
the proper way you're supposed to
develop immunity is I thought the actual
term is about 30 oh you do a little bit
but it's like be around the shit's a
build up your music that's like the
natural way like how kids they build
their money by playing in the sandbox
and then they lick this like that and
eventually they're like well over
licking is the way to do it i think i
build my immunity pretty damn well but
that's how it's please immune so the
reason people don't like hand sanitizers
is because you kill everything so now
the slightest thing will [ __ ] you up
so you're supposed to get little bit of
doses of their owners here and there and
then you get okay well not you so super
quarantine makes me so sterile to the
point where I'm two weeks
next time the cold comes around we are
[ __ ]
yeah we're gonna be just like what
happened to the native populations of
all over the world but you know what to
be is crazy because during the whole
quarantine I've felt so healthy me to it
because you and Chia I know it's pretty
cool I'm just like a losing weight in
three months no way you do brick I see
Rick and I've seen David to shoot the
little kitchen episodes of Senna foods
but you guys are the first like not in
my house
shoot that I've been on in three months
whoa yeah and Shiah was like oh my god
I've been with you every day for three
months I might she's like what does it
take smallpox back to her I've never had
the chicken pox
Oh kidding no I swear that's how I got a
scar in the middle of my [ __ ] head I
got chicken pox when I was a kid I
scratched it yeah I scratched it off a
bunch it's like right here--like
like right back say that's how I got the
scar some kid with chickenpox just
picked me in the nose
yeah but not never had it so [ __ ] you've
never got the vaccine either yeah
there's a vaccine that yeah yeah it came
out in the 90s that's why we didn't get
it I don't remember getting it now no I
got the ID I get the vaccine I got
chicken pox I got the real pox
me too I got a small plum you all got up
at 10:00 ha ha ha ha
you're not scared together get in also
die yeah it's worse as an adult bro I
know we get shingles Oh God like it's
jingle it like that chicken pox thing
when you're older it can turn into
shingles they're not skating yoga
shingles no I won't get it in and get
chickenpox oh we can look at my brain
goes I thought we got vaccine here no
yeah I'm just like in the back of my
mind like let's say I have babies in the
future and then they go to school they
get silly you're getting because they
have the vaccine now oh [ __ ] then I'm
good to go
[Music]
[Music]